good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast and a happy tuesday
it's doomsday because dude
is in the studio and he parallel parked
it right next to me and again you're
being so accepting and loving of the
situation because he's just trying to be
close to and protective of his cousin i
am such an accepting and loving person
period like i don't think anyone should
be surprised right no and we're not but
i just if anyone's listening as a
podcast like claudia is being accepting
no i gave up like
theo doesn't want to sit with me like
he'll be back he'll be back well by the
way let's just get right into it because
today's a sickening the merch warehouse
down
day we dropped our fall collection
shopify is quaking everyone's quaking
head over to shopmorningtoast.com to get
all your fall essentials your crewnecks
your crop tops your stickers like
everything the stickers are so cute your
tumblers your t-shirts so i am wearing
the collegiate black crop tea today and
for like with my big belly and
everything and i'm wearing a size medium
so i didn't even have to oversize that
much it's so comfortable and it goes
down to like my belly button i don't
feel so exposed it's like the perfect
crop t-shirt i'm like so excited by it
and i feel so free in it like because um
it's a very
breathable material and i'm just like
this is my new favorite shirt you look
stunning you should wear this shirt to
the party tonight you should and this
hat to the party tonight um i'm sipping
out of my morning chose tumbler that
comes in two different styles one is our
classic logo and the other is thirst
monster so embrace your inner thirst
monster with our new tumblers um
requests for tumblers for years these
are custom babies to make sure that they
were so sickening and exactly as we
wanted so and like we are literally
saving the planet with our tumblers oh
yes no more plastic straws
we've got you have your straw in
properly today i put my shirt on
properly today how neat is this there's
a little stopper at the end of the straw
i didn't know that oh i noticed it
yesterday but i just thought you were
you know being my quirky self just yeah
you're not like other girls you're not
going to use your straw like i certainly
don't drink like other girls that's what
i thought but i'm glad to see that you
learned something new so i'm wearing
this navy crew neck that also comes in
the hunter green and i for the record
wear xl in all of our
crew necks so if you're looking for a
cyber rest
a size reference like you're as gorgeous
and stunning as me i would go with the
xl but it can never hurt to size up you
know yeah i wear a medium and all the
crew necks because i like them to be a
little roomy and it's now that i'm
pregnant they're not roomy at all
and
when for my sorority crew neck i wear an
extra large because i used to like want
to wear that as a dress
so those are my sizes medium or extra
large in the shorts i wear a medium also
so it's just about how you want it to
fit i would say those crew necks
are the same um people like because
you've you've seen how you during
crewnecks those were very thick same as
the redheads same as the redheads these
crew necks are different these are more
similar to like hundred percent
beautiful stunning and smart they're a
little bit more like but they're still
totally warm and perfect for fall we're
so perfect for fall some could argue
we're falling into fall right now yeah
no we are all the
faultings i like that
how did you think of that this morning
when i was writing the caption for
the instagram i was like go to shop
morning toast for all the fall tings i
was like all the
faultings love that
okay well the merch is out
shopmorningtoast.com not airmaids.com i
know it's really really confusing but
it's shop morning toast
not chanel.com even though with these
lukes we're currently stuntin
it's easy to get confused it is easy to
get confused it's such sickening stuff
so head over there get cozy for fall i
mean the the sweater set that's like the
shorts and the long sleeves is just the
best like that outfit is just like
begging you well not in the in the
outfit but it's begging you to enjoy a
chili not make because you'll stay in it
okay a hundred percent
and i first of all remember i was
talking [ __ ] about ben like i was 100
wrong he had some chili for lunch there
was so much left for me that when i got
home last night from the best night of
my life i have to tell you about it i
want to hear all about it i finished the
whole chili and it was like i said to
ben i'm like we need to have a rotating
tupperware of chili like it is so
premium like i had scooped some tostitos
i was having the craziest [ __ ]
heartbreak in the middle of the night
though like literally ran out of bed
twice to get tums like
i drank like some tequila and then also
chili like it was not a good oh wow
that's hurting my heart wouldn't trade
it for the world that's so beautiful i'm
so glad to see that this chili is just
like filling every crevice of your heart
i know and like it's it's gone now will
you make another one could i because
some there's
it's not like chili is the most
delicious food like can be served in so
many different ways i love to consume a
chili but like the act of making a chili
is also quite fun it's part of
cultivating a vibe you put on a little
music and like you're technically
cooking but it's like not that deep yeah
and and then like you put your mood
lighting on and like some candles it's
just like it's the act of cooking a
chili that's just as delicious as the
chili itself and we're fully in chili
season now it was in the 40s this
morning i saw the weather snatch kept me
up to date the weather snatch oh thank
god for her um
i have to tell you about literally what
was the most amazing night of my life
please do so brian was like i got
tickets to see a drag show with tina
berner do you want to come and tina
berner i feel like i've spoken about her
a lot she was one who performed at
margaret joseph's pride party we saw her
she was she was amazing um she's from
drag race and she was booted off
prematurely like a hundred percent like
she did not go as far as she should have
gone
and it was like a monday and i was
honestly just like not down
so she was at like 9 30 i'm like oh my
god i'm gonna be in bed by then but then
i was like you know what i'll just go
so we went for dinner and we went to
barracuda which brian says is like his
favorite drag spot but he hasn't been
since before the pandemic but they're
still killing it and they're doing um a
miss barracuda pageant so for the last
six weeks they've been doing a pageant
talent competition we went for um they
did like a video competition and like a
q a and it was like a cute pageant in
between tina burner was doing numbers
and jackie
i really don't know how to explain
first of all like tina berner is so
toasty in the sense when you think drag
queens you think they lip-sync
popular music which of course they do
but i've never seen and i don't know if
this is a trend in drag but tina burner
puts together these like skits almost
that use popular
sounds from she was using bring it on
that's what she did at margaret's party
too and this was a new sound i hadn't
heard so she's like doing monologues
from bring it on yeah interspersed with
like celine dion songs and it at all
like telling a story and like these
viral videos like it jackie it was so
funny i was losing my mind and i was
like of course i knew i literally knew
everything that she was talking about
she was amazing the competition was
amazing and then it was like
10 30 and there was another show
afterwards but i was like i really
should go home
let me just see this new show like see
what this queen is about
jackie
her name was izzy uncut and she was
unbelievable she did a similar thing to
tina putting together these like really
funny
sounds full of music full of monologues
from popular movies tv shows videos and
first of all she did a whole skit okay
so like i was like dying and then in
between her um
in between her song she was like oh my
god you're like obsessed with me and i'm
like no i'm literally obsessed with you
so she did a song by lady gaga a million
reasons interspersed with there could be
a hundred people in a room
and every time she said that and all it
takes is one she was looking at me
it was so funny it was so creative the
dancing the singing i was just in awe
like honestly it was like nothing i'd
ever seen before it was unbelievable the
place was packed the finale of the miss
barracuda pageant is next monday
you guys if you are around i think you
should go are you gonna go i get back
from rome that night so like i'll really
have to see like where my priorities lie
there's a delay but it was when i told
you i think i watched drag for like four
hours and you know what ben came and he
loved every minute of it it was so good
like i haven't really seen that many
drag
shows in person i became obsessed with
drag race during the pandemic i've
probably seen drag like three times yeah
oh and this one just took the cake it
was
spectacular i'm so happy for you that
sounds amazing you
would have
jackie you would have like you would
have died it was
i i can't even i can't i'm speechless
like it was
a blending of so much pop culture which
i didn't even expect pop culture dance
their looks death drops cartwheels back
handsprings in the middle of a bar like
it was
the most entertaining few hours i've
experienced in the last couple years wow
it was unbelievable like
and and you know what's so crazy about
that it's a free show it was free yeah
and so you like take out cash and you
give tips and you request songs and you
support the bar i don't know how it
works like buy food and drinks and stuff
to have a table no wow no it's literally
a free show i was just like i need to
support i was like running to the atm
running to the bar support support it's
a free show i'm like you couldn't pay
like you could you should pay a thousand
dollars for this like yeah it was
amazing
it's called barracuda and it's on 22nd
and 8th and it was amazing i'm sure like
all like the gay new yorkers listening
to us were like yeah we know like i
don't i guys i just found out it's
unbelievable that's so exciting i'm so
glad you had such a wonderful experience
i'm extremely jealous but i'm so happy
for you i so wish you were there like
jackie sounds like everything
life-changing they were pulling these
memories out one of the queens did a
monologue do you remember that
acuvue oasis commercial astigmatism with
the two twins yeah of course she
memorized the whole thing as both twins
she was like well i've got astigmatism
but i don't like it was amazing like it
was so [ __ ] good so [ __ ] funny oh
premium content up the wazoo
wow
incredible brian yet again showing me
like what i'm missing out on in life
literally literally how was your evening
my evening was
the opposite
i read all night because i started this
new book uh this tenderland which
everyone says is like an amazing book
you know if you love crawdads you gotta
read it well i won't be reading it yeah
do you have you read crawdads no you
told me i would hate it i i don't think
you would enjoy it it's not for everyone
and
so i finished it last night and it was
so good but it was just
no it was so good i gave it four stars i
didn't like it as much as dana clearly
because she gave it like a 4.9 which is
like off the charts
for dana it was um
but it was like a you know a lot it was
a journey and it was very long but it
was so well written and it was a great
story and i love the way that it ended
and and i mean i spent like six hours
last night reading it so you know it was
good almost did you make a chili to go
with it no what did you make i what did
i have for dinner oh we we ordered but
earlier in the day i used some of my
extra caesar and made this caesar salad
and i've also been making grilled
cheeses trying to make them like more
premium with like the mayo i know like
what you know that like the key to a
good grilled cheese and it has nothing
to do with the taste because you don't
taste it is to put a little mayo on the
outside and that gives it the crisp or
butter no it's like mayo is you're
kidding me so like i had fresh breath
you had mayo yeah but you don't taste it
it just makes it really crispy
i'm gonna puke you're gonna be okay i do
think i've probably had grilled cheeses
would that have mayonnaise on it yeah
like from diners and stuff yeah it's
just like the the best way to get the
crisp i'm sorry i've really been working
on my grilled cheese game the first one
was too burnt the second one was too
cheesy maybe today's the day i get it
right
using potato bread brioche potato bread
is so divine yeah but i got a fresh loaf
so so emily mariko do you know what that
means
the salmon really but she's also just
like an overall lifestyle wellness
cooking farmer's market girly constantly
has slicing her own bread oh interesting
i was slicing my own bread putting her
herbs in water like what does that do i
don't even understand but you you should
really watch her videos i think it'll
inspire you because you're in this very
much like homemaking i think this tastes
like nesting yeah
yeah watch emily mariko she's but then i
think i would just like feel like
insufficient like i don't have herbs i
use like dried ones from the can no
totally and she's like all this gorgeous
tupperware that she like stores her
things from the farmer's market and i'm
like where do you even get these
tupperware's you gotta go to a
tupperware party
that's so true
um i had one more question i wanted to
ask you when you were talking about your
book
and so i'm going to start something new
i've been done like a reading kick oh
and i tried the new kindle
because zach has the kindle oasis so i
just snagged it for a read and it's
really real it's really nice but it's
not worth like you don't have to buy one
but like now it's like maybe i should
just stick with that one it's clearly a
superior it looks pretty big like it's
nice and i do think i was probably
reading more because the page is bigger
and like no i actually love making my
font enormous five words per page yeah
and then i'm just like tap tap tap tap
tap tap tap when i'm reading so fast tap
tap tap yeah
but then like your hand gets you need to
get the clicker i know by the way it's
not even that my hand gets hurt i'm like
i'm getting comfortable and i just like
move my hand you need the clicker yeah
the clicker works by the way i finally
found a bluetooth kit no no it's not
bluetooth it's just a kindle remote and
it works and it's i'll link it again on
my
instagram because it's what we've been
asking for yeah i can't believe it's
here no and it works we
looks like we made it
oh god we've
yeah we are seeing two different songs
which one did you say i sing the um
looks like we made it
that's who sings that one i don't
[ __ ] know the beatles okay
aerosmith okay um one of them anyways so
that's that's all that's new with me i
mean we have a lot to talk about today i
would love your toasters day i know i
would love to delay the stories as long
as possible because
there's one that just
it's hard to remain optimistic oh no oh
yeah well if you want to talk about you
know what i'm singing this morning where
the [ __ ] is brian laundry like
why can't people find him and where's
dog the bounty hunter like get on it i
don't know
what is going on like there are people
convinced that like his parents are like
actually hiding him like beneath their
garden which like i don't think it's
true but really how hard could it be to
find one bald man
i don't know i mean i feel like his
parents were hiding him do they not have
a warrant for his parents house i don't
know
they like somebody took a drone over
their backyard and saw the garden and
it's like there's a bunker beneath oh my
god but like where is hay like i just
don't feel like it's that hard to find
someone especially when everyone knows
what he looks like that's like trying to
find kim kardashian now like we all know
what he looks like yeah
that's true we've got a good story about
kim today she's solving crimes
yeah it's a really crazy story
oh
at the met yeah yeah yeah all right
let's get into it let's get right into
it because without further ado who's
right here just being like the perfect
nephew couldn't ask for anything more
i'm so far so close yet so far away i've
never missed theo more than i do right
now
he's sending love your way
without further ado and talk about it do
here are the fast five stories like
without further ado and without further
talk about a dude oh i got it okay okay
here are the fast type stories that you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your morning toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
all birds we're settling into fall you
guys life is picking back up again and
these days staying comfortable is at the
top of everybody's list including ours
and that's where all birds wool runners
come in they're super soft they're itch
free and they're naturally durable zq
certified merino wool so it's the most
sustainable wool that you can get so you
feel comfortable wearing the wool
runners but you also feel good about
your decision to wear them too because
they're totally sustainable
they're super stylish i mean everyone is
wearing all birds
like just with my all birds i've been
wearing them to like work out for years
but i just got a fresh pair and i went
for a walk last week and it was just
such a premium experience
walking on clouds kitty perry said it
passed i'm walking on air to
tune
tonight i'm walking on it
um so all boards is a carbon neutral
company thanks to sustainable practices
like using natural materials and
purchasing carbon offsets so again
they're just a fabulous company that
look fabulous feel fabulous and
everyone's wearing them so the name on
everybody's lips is all birds start the
season off right with a pair of wool
runners from the all birds uh new
wool runners find your own pair at
allbirds.com today that's
a-l-l-b-i-r-d-s
dot com
um wool runners at allbirds.com you're
you're they're so amazing
the name on everyone's lips what's the
actual
the name it's not it's burlesque
no no it's what is that like yay game on
everyone lips it's it's gonna be roxy
thank you roxy from erica jane's play
that she wrote exactly okay first story
you guys
people are saying that lala and randall
are done after three years of engagement
but i heard that you actually have a
different source saying something else
yeah no i definitely have heard some
other things so i'll share that but you
know page six is reporting that it's
over for lala and randall the vanderpump
role star left her fiance and is staying
at the beverly hills hotel with their
seven-month-old daughter ocean
after the movie producer allegedly
cheated on her in nashville a source
exclusively confirmed to page six the
source said randall always lives a
double life he lives the life of a
husband or boyfriend and then he lives
the life of a serial partier and then
goes on a bender
reps for the couple didn't respond to
page six's comments so i do want to say
like i'm not trying to be in denial but
i do think it's worth noting like this
is page six is reporting this based on a
source like yeah lala hasn't said
anything randall has it's not a
confirmation and they've both been
posting on social media like while i got
a pair of you know jordans for ocean and
she was posting them so it's not like
they've gone silent and they also
haven't confirmed this so even though
it's probably true you know all signs
are pointing towards truth there's like
a
tiny tiny grimace of hope there is a
tiny grimace of hope and maybe like
they're not together right now maybe
they will get back together i did wind
up seeing the photos i do think they can
be explained maybe that was a business
deal maybe that was a business deal they
were gonna do a wine together they
wanted to talk about it at the hotel in
nashville maybe all of them just happen
to be on the same floor in like the
hotel you know stranger things have
happened
but
it's really disappointing and i mean you
know
if it walks like a duck
and talks like a duck then maybe randall
did just cheat on lala and i'm sure she
probably also has information that we
don't have of course whoever took that
picture and like sent it around the
internet probably also dm terms like oh
and i also took this video and this and
that the only thing that i don't really
feel like tracks in this story is like
this is so classic randall he has two
lives and he's a serial partier when
like he's the one who really encouraged
la la to get sober i don't really i mean
obviously i don't know him at all but i
don't really see him being the serial
party or he might have a problem staying
faithful but i don't
really see that i agree i and
based on what she shared like i think
when they're together they're pretty
much
sober but who knows what he does when
he's not with her in terms of like
extramarital affairs and also like
drinking and partying yeah i don't know
i mean this is just disappointing also
like the mother and the child really do
get the house like randall should be at
the top i was thinking that and also
he's out of town so they should like he
was in nashville maybe then like so he
[ __ ] someone in the house and she
doesn't want to be there no but he has
his kids now oh so maybe they're at the
house yeah so like he's not gonna maybe
she it's not gonna displace them
you know because of him can i just talk
about your nails for a moment they're so
long they're literally look like what
kylie pays like a thousand dollars per
nail for like they look like acrylic
those are your natural nails these are
my natural nails on prenatal vitamins
um yes so that middle one on your left
hand
yeah is the craziest [ __ ] claw i've
ever seen in my life it's crazy but look
at this stub it broke but you know what
okay so this broke but it was actually
not a natural break because remember
when i cut my finger
with the knife cutting a bagel a few
weeks ago oh of course a bagel so i cut
into my nail a little bit and it was it
had been glued
like when i went to get a manicure and
then it just gave up so i do think this
nail this little stub would have stood a
chance
if not for that but then also like this
one's starting to fray like they are
starting to
i guess
like when i got a manicure last week i
was like please don't i was like don't
cut i'm just going to file i want to see
how long
i think they are starting to get too
long but it is crazy how like the
difference is is now they're strong
because before prenatals my nails would
grow but they always break on the side
yeah in the middle of the nail the most
painful crack and so i had to get rid of
them
i don't have those cracks now can i ask
you a question and i would love to hear
other people's input on this like just a
personal preference if you have long
nails whether they're real or fake no
let's talk about real you have real
nails they're super long you finally got
them to a good spot
and one of them breaks do you cut all of
them you just leave the broken one
so i think that i will i'm not going to
cut them all down to stub size but after
the stub incident i am going to cut them
because i think it was like a warning
like yes nails you don't want them all
to happen but i'm just saying not when
you're pregnant like i know a lot of
people like they have a philosophy with
their nails like if one of them breaks
they all go down and we start from
scratch which i think is [ __ ] nuts no
if one usually if one of them is breaks
you're on your own 100 this like now
this is but i know a lot of people who
will use that as like all right time to
start fresh with the nails we're just
going to cut them all and start growing
again which i just think is such a waste
if two or three break then then we're
starting fresh fine yeah just thought
i'd bring that up yeah no they are
really crazy i was trying to share with
everyone on my instagram like how wild
it is but i also felt like the pictures
didn't do it justice are you getting
hairy anywhere isn't that also what
those name vitamins do well i did just
german playing my face not
you got a beard no but i had more peach
fuzz than ever really yeah um but i also
hadn't done it like in a year
but it doesn't make you hairier
but i i do think my hair is growing
faster that's why when i cut my hair
short two weeks ago i was like i don't
care it's gonna be long again soon and
like can just a regular person take
prenatals yes but will i start to grow a
baby
no you they're really good for you and
so i always like people would always say
that like you should take them before
you get pregnant you should keep taking
them after you give birth but you know
what they're so big and gross
are they swallow or chewy you can do
chewables the chewables don't have as
much vitamin content as the swallows
like how big
it's the biggest pill i think i've ever
taken oh i would gag i used to gag every
single time now it's gotten much more
pleasant i don't know what the
difference is maybe i'm just like less
nauseous maybe you're just
getting used to this horse throat's
getting bigger maybe
but yeah no it's a it's a crazy thing
happy for you thank you with my literal
lovely ass
your step stubs
remember and used to get fake nails i
know you know i in my time hop they come
up and like i loved it so much it was
like a three hour process like i just
can't sit like that anymore like i have
a job me neither i mean nobody has
crazier nails in the snatcher like not
her real [ __ ] long nails who have
long nails like you who look like they
have acrylic nails are literally the
people in the world i am most jealous of
and if you have long skinny fingers like
that is just like a whole other level
like i want to be you like how does it
feel to live my dream
no the snatchers nails are crazy because
not only do they stay long like they
don't break she's tough as nails that
snatch she's a lizard she also takes the
time every week to get like a detailed
manicure so she has like the perfect
hands and then she's always wearing her
cool rings and things and it's just like
hey it's a snatcher
no like there are two types of girls in
this world like long skinny fingers
short fat fingers and it's important
that you come to terms with which one
you are
because
there's really nothing you can do about
it
it's true
and i do think sometimes like when you
try and like dress up your short fat
fingers with it makes it worse yeah
you're drawing more attention to like
the big meaty hands in front of you
no my my fingers are very
slim
you could say that yes but i don't feel
like i have a slim hand you do you're
you have slim hand i just want to say
for how fat i am like in my body my hand
could be worse so like maybe let me see
it like
it's
it's not terrible but like for me i find
that this part of the hand is so ugly
like in general all right you're getting
really specific with you you're like
that scene in mean girls i have really
bad breath in the morning
the bottom half of my hand is not
attracted like what
i'm just saying if we're if we're
talking about hands like no but you know
what i did find really interesting on
the real housewives of beverly hills
reunion when they were like the first
five minutes like all right everyone get
to get your seats and they're all like
calling out for the hair and makeup and
someone was like can you get me my hand
makeup yeah i think it was rina yeah old
lady hands can be
quite jarring yeah i could use some hand
makeup sometimes but of course the kkw
foundation
anyways
maxwell and randall um wishing their
family the best hoping they can work
through this hoping they can work
through this not giving up hope but
it's not a good situation
it's not it's not
so we'll leave it at that for now
but in some more positive couple news
beyonce and jay-z are cozying up in a
romantic ad for tiffany's inspired by
breakfast activities have you seen i saw
it on at the store yeah the store in new
york is like undergoing renovations so
the whole building is just one big ad
and they just recently changed the ad to
this new beyonce and jay-z it was anya
taylor joy who was also looking gorgeous
also looking gorgeous but this ad is
everything of the sort it comes with
like an accompanying video where they're
playing on the breakfast at tiffany's
theme um it's a short film called date
night that shows the loving playful side
of their relationship inspired by the
new york city backseat taxi scenes from
the 1961 film breakfast at tiffany's the
video begins with a glam beyonce sitting
in the back of a rolls-royce applying
red lipstick and some draw jaw dropping
tiffany and co jewels i have to say this
is a sickening campaign i actually like
when you live in new york there's
campaigns everywhere there's ads
everywhere i almost got hit by a car
like i was very struck by it it's first
of all it's such a big billboard because
the whole building is wrapped in like a
scaffolding while they're under
construction but they turn the whole
thing for this photo shoot it is so
jarring and it's so glamorous it's so
rich it's it's really a work of art it
really is and the harking back to
breakfast at tiffany's
when it's never hurt tiffany's never
hurts never hurts no it's a 10 out of 10
on the ad scale like ad week is quaking
they really they crushed it oh my god i
i lost my triangle what were you going
to sing maybe i'll lend you mine no no
no no
that's fine
no
i'll lend you mine if you tell me what
you're doing i want to surprise you okay
and like you really can't guess it
henna said what about breakfast at
tiffany she said i think i remember the
film and as i recall i think if you
didn't listen to that song like on your
way to school that and like i don't want
to be by gavin degraw
you weren't living like as you fall
asleep on the bus and like wake up and
then it's like
and i said what about breakfast the
she said who sings that song
deep blue something i don't know d blue
stuff no it clear i don't know
d blue something that's a no that's are
you sure deep blue something
okay yeah that's i mean i know the song
give me my [ __ ] thing back i think
theo ate my triangle no i'm sure it just
fell through the couches
um
i'm so glad that song like resonated
with you in such a deep way it did it
not with you no it's a good like i know
it's a good song i wasn't like listening
that wasn't my best jam i feel like if i
called olivia right now and i'd be like
what does this song remind you of i
think me and olivia had the same like
life experience with that song i don't
think so should i call her yeah call her
see if she picks up facetime or regular
do
facetime just let her know she's
honestly recorded yeah not to say
anything oh she [ __ ] let sent me to
decline she oh okay
hurtful well i'll get back to you on
that so what song do you kind of
associate with like early mornings
getting you know me it's all fall out
boy panic at the disco oh no
and i think for olivia it's more in that
vein too because olivia and i are closer
and they age and have this no but
it is like i got an ipod and i remember
that's when i started listening to it on
the way to school and olivia was the one
with the computer and um
limelight limewire like i didn't know
until she whenever i wanted music i had
to be like olivia will you put music on
my ipod and so we just listened to
whatever she was downloading yeah so
literally all the music i listened to
growing up was you [ __ ] you guys were
like that's an interesting point no
because also like i had my own computer
so i wasn't listening to levi's playlist
so i was 100 maybe
i see what i see what you're saying i've
actually never really felt so old like
talking about like my ipod and having to
have olivia put it like her lime wire on
it i know but it was like napster
no naps like yes napster was before
limewire but it was also like before you
like we really use limewire a lot
limewire but also that was like illegal
right limewire yes so like
we didn't use that no a legend well i
admire allegedly when you would also
download music sometimes you would get
like really janky songs and i feel like
i've said this before yes that had like
stamps on it so like when i whenever i
hear the song um
who says you can't get stoned turn off
the lights and the telephone
me in my house alone who says i can't
get stoned
john mayer.com yeah they had like weird
um
like commercials they called a watermark
for watermark yeah yeah
um
gotta miss my ipod i know
like my first ipod was literally the
most important thing in my life and ipod
nano that was my first like the little
black one before like ipod touches and
all that stuff like which were sick
obviously
right but when it was just you in the
pod
what was your first ipod
the uh the white one with the scroll oh
like the circle yeah yeah like the other
that's og yeah no i got the the nano
yeah and then they had the ipod shuffle
the little clip one that you like could
clip to your jacket yeah that's such a
snitch yeah
that one's stuck because it had no
screen like you couldn't see what you
were listening to yeah but it was like
you know it was perfect for like the
younger siblings yeah
because they don't deserve like all the
bells and whistles ipods are so iconic i
know
and the music just like sounded better
from them like totally
good times
good times um are you ready for our next
story if it's brought to you by
peacock's original one of us is lying it
is five students walk into detention and
only four walk out alive follow the
story based on the number one new york
times best seller one of us is lying
which has now been turned into a peacock
original on the first day of school yale
said bronwyn baseball star cooper
cheerleader addie and drug dealing nate
all lend themselves in detention with
the notorious gossip blogger simon when
one of them doesn't make it out alive
everyone becomes a suspect each with
their own secrets and motives this juicy
teen drama takes unexpected new twists
as we find out who's hiding what in his
can't miss new series with romance
betrayal secrecy and more one of us is
lying is the murder mystery of the
season so don't miss out on one of us is
lying streaming now only on peacock go
to peacocktv.com
to get started thank you claudia
it's a pleasure
[Music]
okay our next story is a little art
crime kim kardashian news she'll solve
any crime by dinner time
kim kardashian's met gala photo helped
solve looted gold egyptian coffin case
so somebody had stolen the the coffin
yeah and they sold it to the met under
false papers and then kim took a picture
with it at the met gala and then they
like realized that that's where it was
oh so somebody didn't steal it from the
met when the met purchased it it was
stolen goods i believe so i'm gonna i'm
gonna read through the details because
you know this is involved it's literally
ocean's
12
13. whatever whatever the one that was
at the met gala eight eight
in a wild turn of events a photo of kim
kardashian rocking a gold dress at the
2018 met gala i believe her best met
gala look ever and claudia agrees
has led to something quite unexpected
solving a mystery a viral snap that
showed her posing next to the coffin of
ned
monks has led to the conclusion of a
long-running criminal case involving the
golden artifact in a recent episode of
journalist ben lewis's podcast art bust
you'd just love to see like podcasts
making news podcast making news kim
making news art making news
the podcast is called art bust
scandalous stories of the art world he
doll dives into how the thing is are
there that many that they needed to
start a podcast for sure like
there's so much art drama drama crime
and it's been around for so i'm sure
there's crazy stories so many forgeries
there's so many stories i'm sure
i'm sure ben has
plenty of content
he dives into how the photo played a
role in catching the thieves who stole
the coffin and sold it to the
metropolitan museum of art for four
million dollars by using fake documents
before that the coffin which date backs
to the first century bc was dug up from
the almenia region of egypt in 2011
during that year's revolution
the manhattan assisted d.a was notified
of kim's photo standing next to the
coffin by an anonymous tipster not the
d.a the d.a was notified of the car was
it raphael
um
he's the best da in town he was notified
of kim's photo the da was sent kim's
photo by an anonymous tipster in the
middle east who originally received the
image from a gang of pillagers so kim's
photos going around the informant was
irritated that they were never paid for
unearthing the coffin seven years before
by the time he talked to the informant
the d.a had already opened up a jury
investigation but so what was it about
kim's photo that was like the last
missing piece of this investigation i
guess they didn't realize that it and
that it turned up at the met
oh those people who sold it the people
who were looking up
yeah
okay this is i need a film about this
because it's not making sense or you
could listen to the podcast i'm sure he
has a better job of explaining it just
all i know is kim kim saved the day yeah
it does give me like ptsd though like
all these gangs like looking at kim and
like kim and her pictures like leave him
alone you know and did that come to mind
for you
what like all these like gangs crime
gangs like who would have thought like
kim's just taking like an innocuous
picture at the met because she's like
dressed similarly and it's not even like
like a fabulous picture it's like blurry
i hadn't even seen it either because
it's not a good one it's probably like
went right into her into her trash
like you know delete yeah yeah it's like
blurry and there's like a
beam of light in the middle like it's
not a gorgeous photo at all that is so
crazy i wonder what she thinks about
this you know i know like does this
stuff get back to her i think i think
this would be because it's a very
serious thing and it's also pretty crazy
and cool mm-hmm you know but i'm sure
not every you know she doesn't read
every she doesn't google alerts for
herself no
because her phone would break i just
want to say i have google alerts on for
for us like the morning toes you're the
most boring
literally the morning toast google alert
is one of the most painful things to
read every morning you try avocado with
your morning toast
i i um french toast recipe i don't have
google alerts for the toast then because
i i only have google earth for myself
and i'm the most boring least famous
person ever no same once a year nothing
comes out nothing once a year and it's
full of lies
allegedly
yeah for sure
so anyways good on kim like love to see
crimes being solved before dinner time
before dinner time
are you ready for our next story i think
it's it's news i don't know how you're
going to feel about it you'll feel good
but i also think you'll have something
to say
well that's what i came here to do
netflix's to all the boys franchise will
be getting a spin-off series titled xo
kitty starring the little sister who's
played by anna cathcart
netflix is expanding its hit to all the
boys i've loved before franchise with a
brand new entry the streaming giant
announced on monday that has picked up a
10 episode order of a new young adult
series titled xo kitty which is a
spin-off to the popular movies trilogy
of films that were previously
previously released the new show will
center around the character of kitty
song covey
who's played by anna cathcart you guys
might also know her from descendants oh
really she plays drizzy yeah oh well let
me say this
i definitely have something to say
because i have to say probably the one
complaint i had in the movie was that
that sister was really annoying and she
had too much of a role and like i just
didn't enjoy her
but having said that will i be watching
the show no is it for me no so maybe the
young kids like who watch that movie who
are literally 15 years younger than me
but also like the movie maybe they were
like you know drawn queen yeah so i
think maybe this is not a show for me
but i just like if i had to make a spin
off of anything i honestly would give it
to like
either two people like
john corby ends up with his neighbor
right
i never saw the third one and then it
could be like a nancy myers movie like
he finds a nice woman across the street
that could be one or you know who's like
a really undervalued character in the
franchise is um i can't remember
anyone's names it's been so long lara
jean's friend who's was cousins with the
bully
yes she's like this wild host oh yeah
like she was just like wild gal like i
don't know i would watch a series like
christie chris chris chris yeah i think
she would be
amazing like she's like
but i don't know maybe they're trying to
skew younger yeah no i don't think they
have a problem with you know getting the
john corbett down right to netflix they
should do a nancy meyer spin-off john
corbett and you know
how like they blend their families
it's called blended too by nancy myers
yeah no i agree i thought you would like
this news because it's like more to all
the boys
but then you would also feel
meh about it because you know is it the
best premise i'm not sure no i'm sure
it'll be fine it'll be good but it's not
for you no it's not for me and that's
okay but you know what you know what
it's for it's for the campers it's for
the cambers
but um did you see that they released a
few photos from the summer i turned
pretty
no um so jenny han like launched
like the twitter account for the series
um jenny han wrote to all the wise i
love before and then she also wrote this
other sickening
trilogy which is actually made for
children like i read all three books in
actually one day um but it was so
adorable this like teen romance it was
so sweet and amazon bought it and
they've cast everyone and they're the
kids are just the kids are like quaking
the kids are like good looking it's on
twitter we've gotten like a few sneak
peeks i'm very excited about that i'm
excited for you i'm just trying to find
pictures but i didn't go to the twitter
i didn't read the books
so you didn't no because you said that
like if you felt old reading them yeah i
guess and you said
yeah
it was so sweet though i'm sure it was
oh when that guy like touched her hair
in the car i just like couldn't it was
so sweet i literally like consumed all
but every book like in a day yeah i'm so
good maybe i'll watch the show but i'm
not gonna read the book yeah i'm sure
the show will be cute or it'll be like
really teeny bopper and i'll feel stupid
yeah
anything goes anything can happen
anything goes well i'm feeling really
annoying like show tuned i think it's
like last night yeah like the
inspiration that the drag queens like
left on my soul i think that's a really
good influence you know a hundred
percent are you ready for a fifth and
final story
no i'm actually not
oh my god okay get up and look for your
thing get up yeah like just look in
between the couches if it's not there
then i'll play and you'll sing
and also this gives you guys oh amazing
this gives you guys time to lower the
volume if you have a sleeping baby or
dog or
self or husband
it's the final story
[Music]
no
ah it's become the best part of my day
truly
i want you and i'm literally sweating
from having to stand up
it was worth it
is it worth it oh my god i'm being
really annoying um it was worth it also
the fifth and final story is brought to
you by british do you care i do care
because i love my bro
[Music]
what is bruce it is the official
toothbrush of the morning toast the best
electric toothbrush out there right now
and the most affordable because a lot of
electric toothbrushes have the absolute
audacity to cost over 200 which is
absolutely insane but bruce is super
affordable it gets the job done it's
gorgeous they come in sickening colors
they have amazing accessories it comes
with six unique modes to customize your
brushing experience the battery life
lasts four weeks it comes with a
magnetic charging stand and a compact
travel case they also offer a
subscription program so never forget to
change your brush head again bruce will
ship you a new replacement head
every six months so you're never stuck
using a worn down brush head
the design is very sleek they have a
modern aesthetically pleasing design
that comes in trend driven seasonal
colors and it looks great on your
bathroom counter we've got 15 off your
bruce toothbrush kit and the refill plan
when you use the promo code toast at
bruce.com toast that's 15 off using
promo code toast at b-r-u-u-s-h
dot com
slash toast code toast
thank you claudia
okay our fifth and final story is um a
little more content news for the campers
and also for us because addison ray will
be starring in a snapchat show about
returning to her louisiana roots
addison ray one of tick tock's biggest
creators is going to start on her own
show on snapchat addison ray goes home
will document the influencer actor's
trip to louisiana where she grew up her
first time since moving back to la
since moving to her first time back
since moving to l.a yes to pursue her
entertainment career in the unscripted
series addison will reveal a more
personal side than fans have ever seen
before according to snap the series is
scheduled to premiere in 2022 and is
being produced by maven so i want to say
i think conceptually this is an amazing
idea for a show there's you know we know
addison as the mega star but literally
two years ago she was a college student
like she's just a regular girl i would
love to see her in her hometown but like
snapchat really first of all like who
the [ __ ] is watching that second of all
addison was just in a netflix movie like
this should be like a a demilio show
thing or like a youtube original like
something like snapchat
i mean i guess like her teenybopper fans
like they do love snapchat but i don't
really think people are watching that
long-term long-form content on snapchat
i agree i don't think it's gonna be that
long i'm sure it's like a very short
like 15 minutes sort of series and i'm
sure they're paying her so much money
you know like
it's not ideal for us because i don't
want to watch it on snapchat like i
would rather watch it on youtube or like
youtube yeah if she was trying to be
like a digital gal but i think this is
just um
an easy
job for addison i think for a while when
we used to report on everything addison
did like every step she took was like
the biggest deal because all of this was
so new so when she did item beauty and
then she did the netflix i think that
every choice she made had like a huge
impact on where her career was gonna
land and now she's like a bonafide
celebrity superstar if you will so she
can do things like this that are like
not as no one's even going to notice
this yeah honestly it's just like a drop
this is just a press release and it's a
paycheck it's a paycheck for sure so i
mean i don't think i'll be downloading
snapchat to watch it but um
i would if it was elsewhere but i do
feel like this like it's a missed
opportunity because the concept of the
show is actually very good yeah and i'm
sure the show will be really good like
everyone loves to compare her to
brittany like to louisiana girls like i
just think that her backstory like
actually probably is really interesting
margo told me
and i listened to like the first 10
minutes of her very first podcast
episode with her mom margot kind of gave
me a synopsis of it because like i just
couldn't listen to it um but they have a
very they had a very interesting and
kind of tumultuous life like before all
of this happened so i would actually
love a real show like this but not on
snapchat yeah i agree
um well it's not over yet you guys
because those were the past five stories
and while i didn't feel you needed to
know them i do feel
good knowing them i agree there's no
harm in knowing them absolutely not
today is tuesday which means it's deer
toasters which is our advice segment we
do every tuesday and if you ever want to
write in get some advice from your
favorite gals your favorite gal pals
dear toasters gmail.com is the email you
can write in about anything and we will
always keep it anonymous as we do today
we have a few submissions so i would
love to share them with you if that's
okay i would love to hear what
everyone's up to hi
this is someone else not me sorry i
didn't transition well
all right first up
thank you hey
congrats jackie on the baby longtime fan
and listener of you both i am currently
pregnant with my first girl my husband
michael and i are thrilled for this
blessing we always knew that when and
when and if we have a son we're going to
name him michael with a j middle name
and call him mj my immediate family has
always known this
who stole it yeah who stole the name my
sister
who is not married but has a longtime
boyfriend whose name also starts with an
m texted me randomly at 11 p.m at night
that when she has a boy she's
he is going to be mj
your sister sounds delusional um i would
be remiss if i didn't tell you that i
got the biggest pit i couldn't believe
she had the audacity to text me that
randomly am i ever reacting i knew i
shouldn't count my chickens before they
hatch but this just seems like such a
slap in the face for my sister if you
guys were in the situation with jackie b
annoyed sincerely a disappointed sister
well i just think it's worth noting
first of all you are pregnant
your sister has a long-term boyfriend
but is not pregnant so you will get the
name mj no but she's having a girl and
and that's oh and put that together
that's what she wants to name a boy so
she still has to save it so in all this
time of you know her having the girl and
then whenever she gets pregnant
like this
the sister could slide in i didn't i
didn't see that he was a girl if this
were like someone in my family and there
was a name that like everyone knew
i wanted and i planned on and then like
some sister swooped in and was like i
would just be like what the [ __ ]
you're joking right but also
there's a difference because we have a
bunch of names in our family that we we
like love as family names yeah so
whoever's pregnant gets to choose from
the family name yeah but if this is an
original name that this girl came up
with
you no one's allowed to take it yeah i
agree and that's why you should never
say your your original name idea out
loud ever shall we you should be able to
trust your sisters totally but still
shayla
but this is a betrayal i mean if she's a
betrayal of the highest degree if she's
sister betrayal if she does wind up
betraying you in this way like say you
know a year year and a half like she has
a son before you and
she names him mj like whenever you do
have a son [ __ ] name him nj like yeah
also i just want to throw one thing out
there because just i wanted to let you
know that like personally like my first
reaction to the name mj like was michael
jackson so i just oh no mine was
mercedes oh that's an amazing namesake
i'm naming my child shot it mercedes
shot
nobody's stealing so like that way if
you want to you could name your daughter
mj what about mccabe
michaela j but mj for a girl
oh mercedes javed mercedes jobbing is
normalizing like everything for me right
now right yeah mj for a girl take it
like it's pharrell and michaela i mean
is the most gorgeous and there's take it
from us
the possibilities for nicknames are
endless endless taylor mckayla's like
become my favorite name of all time in
the history of names
and so i think you should really
consider this and then you could also
call her kaler and then kayla taylor
swift
like
no oh my god
sorry are you okay i was just trying to
be like
no oh my god so sorry absolutely not
let's move on
jesus consider michaela and if you're if
you if you're gonna if you're saying no
to that suggestion i understand that's
fine you know it's not for everyone you
know he's gonna be offended like um the
less michaela's there are there and your
sister like does go through with the
betrayal then you should
just still name your son mj and you know
what i'm feeling so kind of like upset
by this portrayal i wrote a song
you picture it's original betrayed
me
and i know that you'll never feel
sorry
for the way i heard
you talk to mj i'm still working on some
of the lyrics but that's pretty much
like the gist of it what do you think i
think it was pretty disappointing like
because it's not an original song but
how could you say that it's really just
heard it right now it's a real song who
sings that olivia rodrigo i don't know i
literally just wrote that song you think
of louie rodriguez that's how good you
think my song was you think olivia
rodriguez wrote it and then the minute
you had to improvise you ran out of
words
and i know that she'll never okay
whatever yes it is olivia rodrigo song
but you didn't even know that so
i did i just said it i know you were
like it's olivia rodriguez like i could
have said it's taylor swift like you
would have known you know yeah that's
true okay
um so that was the first one
that what was our advice
our advice was michaela yeah or
michaela's always the answer michaela's
always the answer or um
just continue forge ahead in your path
don't look in the rear view yeah forge
ahead do whatever you want doesn't
matter what she does because she's a
betrayer
okay are we ready for this next one
dear claudia and jackie congrats on the
baby jackie congrats on your new chore
claudia thank you tickets available at
girlsnowjob.com even though
there's like almost none left okay i'm
in need of dire no i'm in dire need of
advice my best friend is about to get
engaged to someone who's awful she's my
ride or die from college we have another
best friend in our group and we both
feel this way about her man the let's
call the girl rebecca
since college the three of us have all
lived in different states so we didn't
meet this man until later in the
relationship i met him first and
immediately talked to my other friends
but my concerns were just that he was
obnoxious however three months ago the
other best friend in our group met the
man we visited them in the home they
just built together so obviously they're
very serious rebecca and her man have
been together for almost two years and
my concern has since escalated to major
red flags one rebecca cried to us for
cried to us begging for us to be extra
nice to her man and offered to help
clean up after dinner in order for him
to like us
he talks about money nonstop everything
about him is about money and how
now she's doing it too constantly
telling us they make a lot of money when
literally nobody asked
rebecca's man talked horribly about her
other friends who visited before us he
actually said to us that he would rather
murder murder them than have them visit
again hyperbole but very strange overall
he's abrasive he kept saying very
offensive things
to try and instigate fights we chose to
ignore him because we were trying to be
polite there are a bunch of other things
he does that are just ick me and my
friend feel like we need to say
something to her about him rebecca is so
isolated where she lives and doesn't
really have friends of her own there
rebecca found the engagement ring box in
the house so she thinks he will propose
soon my friend said she wouldn't be able
to be a bridesmaid if she marries him
multiple other close friends have
brought up other concerns about him to
me my question is do we say something
and how do we say it we love rebecca so
much and we are concerned please help a
fellow girly girl out we have to do it
for the girly girls because you know i'm
always like just mind your own business
let people make their own mistakes but
like if you're all saying something that
she can't see like
and you have they're not engaging like
you have the chance to do something
wouldn't you want your friends to do
that for you i don't know like you guys
don't have to date him like she's
she's a girl like she makes her own
choices like on the one hand yeah you
have one chance to save her but like
what because you don't like him like
obviously i doesn't sound like i would
like this man either i understand
exactly where you're coming from but at
a certain point like people get to make
their own choices and like when you put
your foot in it like you just stink up
the whole joint like i think no good
deed goes unpunished she's still gonna
get engaged to him and then you guys are
gonna look like unsupportive friends and
how are you ever gonna all hang out
again
like that's fair in reality no like of
course we you've got to stop her like
they built a [ __ ] house together this
girl's not going anywhere yeah and like
maybe she likes him like yeah maybe all
the things that you don't like about him
like are endearing to her or they don't
bother her as much as they bother you or
you know first somehow like the way he
is when they're just alone makes her
happy
and that like the way he is around other
people he's a lot worse version of
himself that's very a lot of people are
like that you know they in group
situations suck and one-on-one they're
totally fine but like this isn't like a
a non-serious relationship where it's
like they haven't moved in together yet
right she doesn't know him and we're
seeing something she doesn't she knows
everything she knows this man she chose
this man um she's excited about the ring
like you could say something if but you
would only be saying it for yourself
actually just to get it off your chest
right not necessarily for her because
she knows him wait it's only she's ever
complained about him to you
so like she's very happy and isn't that
all that matters yeah
and you you don't have to sleep next to
him at night like and it's not a crime
to be annoying by the way like and talk
about money it's [ __ ] annoying but
it's not a crime like sometimes you
don't like the person that your friend
is with yeah
and that's fine
you're not dating them and you know what
like eventually i actually think this is
a really hard part about growing up like
everyone's priorities turn out to be
like their partner and their
relationship the family they're gonna
build together and it's not always about
like friends friends friends like when
you're in college like your friends are
everything so like that transition like
when the first friend is like obviously
building a house and getting married
like it's really difficult because like
what about us like you know we were your
priority forever but everyone the older
you get like you're the family you're
building for yourself becomes your
priority and it sounds like that's what
this girl's doing yeah so if there was
something that she didn't know i would
say tell her you know you saw him
he was talking to this girl you heard
something about him but it's all things
that he's doing like in front of you and
you just want to share your opinion
about it and in front of rebecca
yeah no it's all things that he's doing
in front of her too like she sees
exactly what you see and she actually
sees more because she spends more time
with him and she's still making her
choice i don't
i don't think it's going to be
productive for you to say i just don't
think you're going to get the answer
that you want where she's like yes save
me and you guys all go back to being
roommates like i think she's going to
like then she's going to choose
yeah she's going to choose him and keep
you at arm's length so what would you
prefer yeah the balls in your court
sorry i know that's not what you want no
not at all um there is one more deer
toaster okay and it is brought to you by
spirit society elevate your everyday
with spirit society something made in a
cane made in a can that is made with
real cane sugar it's 120 calories and
it's absolutely delicious we've had uh
well actually you haven't had it yet
because i haven't had it from the can
but i did have it in the trial phases it
comes in four flavors as you guys know
our family is involved with this brand
it's amazing they're wine based canned
cocktails they got grapefruit pineapple
lemonade and
orange which is like kind of a
traditional spritzy flavor they're so
good we obviously have a code for you
guys i can't personally cannot drink
hard seltzers because a lot of people
are like oh a heart seltzer is vodka no
the base of heart seltzer is malt and
for me my stomach does not agree with
mulch jackie was there in the airport
when i was like chugging pepto-bismol
and then i ran to the bathroom in utah
and had diarrhea and threw up um it was
a gorgeous day so
i officially have not drank hard
seltzers in like almost a year and i've
become obsessed with sports society not
only because ben started a company i
swear when i'm drinking i'm like there's
nothing better than this i drink them on
the river i drink them on rooftops i
drink them apartments they're just
everything of the sort
um and there's 120 calories per can and
you can use kotos for 10 off the variety
pack you got to try all the flavors
because i was really into lemonade but
now i'm thinking i'm very much like a
grapefruit girly girl what's so
interesting is everybody has a different
favorite flavor and there's not one
flavor that's like nobody's favorite no
and there's not one that's like the one
that everyone's the front runner yeah
yeah it's really it's more personal than
food or coffee your rice is more
personal than food they also have an
option to subscribe and receive monthly
deliveries that we definitely recommend
because you go through it faster than
you realize so you get sprit society
stocked monthly at a discounted price
but you also get exclusive access to
gift with purchases as well as exciting
new offers coming down the pipeline so
toast is the code on the variety pack
for 10 off at spritsociety.com check it
out i know so many of you have already
ordered it and we love and appreciate
the support but it's really like it's
i'm not even lying it is the best drink
on the market right now like i i don't
know what else to drink yeah it's like
it's kind of like changing my life it's
such a problem solver yes of a
solution-oriented beverage yes jackie i
was literally at like my friend um well
ben's best friend and his
wife although we're like foursome now
you know um we were hanging out and we
were like you guys have any spritz like
yeah of course we have the subscribe
monthly and first of all we went through
like with the four of us in one night we
went through like probably 15 like no
problem and
we were saying i'm like if we weren't
drinking this right now like what would
we be drinking and i don't really even
drink wine yeah but these are wine based
and they're just delightfully all
natural and delicious
so wonderful they're also for me like
whenever i'm going to someone's
apartment or someone's like ready for
the weekend i just like you can bring a
bottle of wine sure but they have like a
million that they threw into their
cupboard no that they literally use like
for making pasta yeah but i now bring
like a can of spritz and it's just like
such a festive cute thing to bring and
bring and it's just like a level up i
that's a great call
um okay our final dear toasters hello
jackie and claudia i have to say that
the podcast has gotten me through some
tough times this past year i lost my
brother in june and you guys have been a
ray of light for me since thank you and
i'm so sorry um now to my petty friend
situation that i need your advice on i
have a really tight circle of best
friends and after i lost my brother last
year
sorry i i read this wrong i have a
really tight circle of best friends and
after i lost my brother last year all of
them except for one ramona made a huge
effort to be there for me i confronted
ramona she said some nasty things and we
naturally had a falling out but she
stayed friends with two of my best
friends
that pissed me off
fast forward a year and multiple
apologies later and i've tried to reach
out to rekindle a relationship inviting
her to my parents lake house for july
4th inviting her to lunch texting her to
check in and even seeing her a couple of
times she blew off my july 4th invite
and i decided not to invite her on a
girls trip for my birthday a weekend i
asked my best friends
to be my bridesmaids
ramona wasn't invited ramona never told
me she was upset about that and i moved
forward with still reaching out and even
invited her to formal engagement party
with my fiance
well this past weekend she had a large
birthday dinner and doesn't invite me
two of my best friends telling two of my
best friend that it's because i'd
invited her to my girls weekend three
months ago am i being petty by
uninviting ramona target party our very
close family and friends will be there
and we're spending over 200 per person
at a 100 person venue
so you're spending
what is that
20 grand wow nice nice eating party
maybe uh invite us yeah we'll take our
spot yeah 100
clearly she doesn't think we're actually
friends and i'd rather focus my night on
hanging out with people i don't have to
question why they're there please help
from an overly overthinking and possibly
dorm out of a toaster i have to say
right from the get-go here i was shook
because check my math oh was that right
yeah yeah okay right from the get-go
here i'm like i don't think this girl if
if there's a friend in your life who you
considered a friend who's not there for
you like
when your brother dies like the hardest
time in your life not a friend first of
all not a friend you're a very nice
person for reaching back out after but i
do think that this relationship is could
put like yeah i don't think you should i
think like you should just wash your
hands a bit like it's so petty back and
forth don't environment party and really
never talk to this [ __ ] again like
there there are things that people do
that are unforgivable and for me like
this is one of them i completely agree
like that would be my response to it
sounded like she already sent out
engagement parties she's the girl's
invited but she's like is it petty if i
disinvite her i think like yes because
then you're getting back into this like
tit for tat with ramona where it's like
let her come to the engagement party
ignore her and please don't ever speak
to her again like what an awful awful
person like she didn't deserve your
kindness when you were the one to reach
out after you were going through a hard
time and the fact that like you invited
her to your parents house for july 4th
and she can't invite you to a birthday
dinner like [ __ ] ramona [ __ ] ramona you
know like you have other wonderful
people in your life you're engaged like
we're moving forward and we're leaving
we're leaving ramona in the in the rear
view and if you feel like that the lack
of ramona in your life is going to leave
some sort of gap like join a local
toaster group and you can find an
amazing friend there like
i really really want you to know like
how little i want you to be friends with
ramona you need to get away from ramona
absolutely and i love that you named her
ramona like it's so appropriate yeah i'm
so
like she's so wrong you sound like a
lovely person for like wanting to
welcome this person back into your life
but it's okay for you to be like you
know what what you the lack of love you
showed me at one of the hardest times in
my life like i really don't think i can
get past so with all due respect like
[ __ ] off and you have so many friends
who were there for you you know focus on
the positives and beyonce you're getting
married leave ramona in the dust peace
out ramona that's the message here good
day ramona good day ramona um so that
was your toaster if you ever want to
write in for some unsolicited fabulous
what i think to be really constructive
helpful advice um dear toasters
gmail.com and if you've written in
recently and we gave you some advice and
you know you either took it the
situation unfolded further do send us an
email with an update we would love to
hear how it's going it's dear toasters
gmail.com i'm not sure if i mentioned
that yeah we would love to hear how it's
going and that's our show tomorrow is
hump day it is my final show of the week
but fred not thursday friday of this
week and monday of next week my husband
ben boy with no job will be filling in
for me with jaquie so thank you once
again for you know picking up the slack
when i could not and really thanks to
ben for hooking it up a lot of people
were wondering like why ben's not coming
with me so yes ben was invited to the
wedding that i'm going to it's one of my
best friends from high school but ben
can't go he has many work commitments
that he couldn't get out of so then i'm
like well if you're not going do my work
yeah add a little more to your plate
um also just a reminder fall merch is
available at shopmorningtoast.com right
now we i wear size medium and everything
this t-shirt size medium the sweatshirts
i've been wearing our size medium except
for the sorority crew i do like that one
in an extra large claude wears an extra
large
they are true to size the only time and
as it is most of our merch our last drop
was ran small but these run true to size
so whatever size you are feel
comfortable ordering that and
i hope you guys enjoy the merch you know
and i i pray for your mailboxes because
they're going to be they're look who am
i who am i
the mailbox yes how did you know oh my
god because they just
i knew
we're so so good
you guys thank you so much for listening
to the morning toast monday morning show
where we deliver the five stories that
you need to know every monday through
friday on youtube so if you're watching
this on youtube please feel free to
subscribe and give this video a thumbs
up we're also available as a podcast and
we're podcasts can be found on spotify
itunes stitch or public radio i have
ready to catch box all the places sweaty
listen to the podcast find this more
until 7 star review about how beautiful
stunning and smart we are and if you
made it to the end of the episode like
most toasters will not you are a special
breed of toaster you are part of the
society season two and to let us know
that you made it here drop an emoji on
our most recent instagram um why don't
you make it the little music note to
honor all the beautiful songs i sang
here today and rest in peace the ipod
yes r.i.p
od
you got that